I built a hundred thousand dollar per
month profit business with no employees
for less than a thousand dollars when I
was twenty six anyone could start the
exact same business with little to no
money at all and no employees I got
asked to speak at this marketing event
so they wanted me to speak about how I
was using Facebook ads to get leads for
brick and mortar in 2016. I would run
ads for six weeks weight loss challenge
and I offered a satisfaction guarantee
that even if they didn't lose the weight
if they wanted their money back at any
point in the six weeks I'd give it back
to that I actually made more money
launching than running the gym I said
I'll fly out to your gym I'll spend my
own money I'll Market your gym for you
I'll work the lead I'll schedule them
and I'll sell them and I'll even do
nutrition orientations which by the way
is where I would sell another 100 150
bucks a head in supplements that would
also cover my costume for our customers
on its own and all they had to do was
just fulfill the six weeks of service